all right February is American Heart
month and the way to a healthy heart is
exercise and healthy food this American
Heart month we're sharing some healthy
recipes for you to try Candace Charles
joins us live from D'Agostino's
Trattoria on Buffalo and Flamingo with a
look at their heart healthy menu and
you're I'm learning something about
their healthy food there Candace I
thought it was just all lasagna and you
know garlic bread but no
well Sherry there is lasagna and garlic
bread here at the casino which I've been
practicing a little bit but they also
have thank you thank you but they also
have some amazing healthy dishes right
in time for Valentine's Day another
heart that we're going to be thinking
about right Chef Dan thank you so much
for joining us tell us about the dishes
here on the table so here we have a
vegan and gluten-free pasta we call it
pasta primavera broccoli spinach cremini
mushrooms again roasted red peppers so
many wonderfully healthy things
um good gluten free penne here we also
have whole grain whole wheat pasta here
as well I have the orange roughy here
New Zealand orange roughy this is uh
just simply pan seared no salt added and
I have it with the puttanesca sauce the
puttanesca does have Capers and olives
which do have some sodium but they're
within the limits of your daily
allowance which is you know usually for
adults 2 300 milligrams a day is is
normal so there's only about 500
milligrams of sodium in the Capers and
olives in the sauce so if you watch what
you're doing throughout the day you can
enjoy at dinner time and be okay yes
absolutely Chef Dan thank you for
creating this wonderful menu which
really they created from one of their
customers so it's quite beautiful
Valentine's Day just around the corner
they said that they already have some
reservations but you can still make more
and another thing first you'll hear here
guys they're going to be opening up this
restaurant a little bit more they're
going to be growing and expanding soon
you'll be able to see a new bar here so
a lot of good things happening here
thank you so much Chef Dan for joining
us this morning you guys I know you want
to see me on camera but you're gonna
have to just wait
oh we have to wait well Chef Dan really
knows his stuff though talking about the
amount of sodium that's great